today on campaign check its SMP
manifesto day and running through their
manifesto it's of course the argument
for Scottish independence his Nicola
Sturgeon on that they claim that
Scotland is not good enough or rich
enough to be independent but when they
need to balance the UK books they always
seem to find billions of pounds of
Scottish resources to do that job for
them
Scottish resources being used to balance
the rest of the UK's books that's a line
the SNP often use to make their case for
independence but are they actually right
on it well the sturgeons says that since
the discovery of North Sea oil the
Treasury pocket it's 340 billion pounds
of revenues from the industry and unlike
Norway which used their revenues to
create an enormous sovereign wealth fund
Scotland's been left with nothing says
the SNP leader but is she right on that
well let's have a look at how Scotland
compares with the rest of the UK and
this line shows you the Scottish
population as a percentage of the UK
total so anything above the line means
Scotland's doing more of it than average
anything below less than average so if I
show you Scottish government spending
you can see it's consistently above the
UK average Scotland does tend to spend
more per head than the rest of the
country now that's not a problem with
Scottish tax revenues were also above
that line and for much of recent history
they were so this line shows you
Scottish revenues including their share
of North Sea tax income for most of the
past couple of decades Scotland's
revenues were well above the UK average
actually above that line of spending so
in one sense the SNP is right the UK did
pocket a lot of Scottish tax but here's
the thing in the past seven or eight
years look at that line the income has
slumped partly thanks to lower oil
prices partly the decline of the North
Sea and this gap between spending and
revenue means Scotland's government
borrowing is now about 7% of national
income let's put that into perspective 7
percent that means Scotland has a bigger
government deficit than any advanced
economy look at Scotland over here you
can see Scotland there right at the
bottom there the biggest deficit and who
has the best surplus the biggest surplus
of all it is Norway so Norway it helps
explain how they can build up the funds
that the SMP say that they want now the
SNP do say they have an answer to some
of us they want to make more revenues
from renewable energy and that billions
are going to be saved by scrapping
trying but because they haven't provided
detail
costings it's a bit difficult to work
out whether that's actually right so
nicolas surgeons claim that UK
politicians use scottish resources to
balance the books was once true but it
isn't anymore